la confederación africana de fútbol
ordenó una investigación y anunció
medidas tras la estampida que ocurrió en
el estadio de doren ve y dejó al menos 8
muertos y 38 heridos en siete de ellos
de gravedad según las cifras oficiales
presidente de la casa de patrice motsepe
en conferencia de prensa admitió que
hubo fallas en el operativo de seguridad
que derivaron en esa avalancha de
personas en el ingreso al estadio antes
del encuentro entre camerún y comoras
además apuntó que los organizadores en
la caf y el gobierno camerunés deben
asumir la responsabilidad de manera
conjunta por otro lado anunció que el
partido de cuartos de final programado
para este domingo en el estadio de oro
en be se va a trasladar al otro estadio
de yaundé el amadou ahidjo we have to
make a dead
tenemos que asegurarnos de que la
seguridad y la salud por supuesto ahora
que estamos enfocados en el joven 19 de
cada uno de los espectadores es nuestra
preocupación principal
y si sólo hay cero tolerancia
absolutamente cero tolerancia con
circunstancias que puedan resultar en
que personas sufran heridas en un
estadio o pierdan sus vidas 7 state of
people to sing the lights se espera que
el viernes en la caf entregue un informe
completo de lo ocurrido y que se
garanticen las condiciones de seguridad
para que se puedan disputar los otros
partidos programados en vez según lo
previsto esto incluye una semifinal y la
final del torneo